on sunday he was hoping to enjoy the
reflected glory of england's success
have you stoked the fire of racism prime
minister
but rather than football coming home
questions over racism have come to his
doorstep
can he tell the house does he now regret
failing to condemn those who booed
england players for standing up to
racism
yes or no
[Applause]
mr speaker we made it absolutely clear
that no one should boo the england team
kierstama said he had evidence to the
contrary here
i have the headline mr speaker boris
johnson refuses to condemn fans
booing england taking the knee and the
problem for the prime minister is that
even the co-founder
of conservatives against racism for
equality has written to tory mps
saying the party's been getting this
wrong it's regrettable
that the abuse that the booing rather
was not condemned
from the beginning it would have been
excellent
if more of our leaders had taken more of
a stand in the same way that we saw
gareth southgate take a stand and i
think the way that he's rallied the
country around that team
has been like nothing i've ever seen in
my lifetime so
what your leader could could learn from
gareth southgate i think all leaders can
learn from gary southgate
following the abuse of bakayou saka
jaden sancho and marcus rashford
the government's promising laws to find
social media companies if they fail to
take down abuse
marcus rashford's mural in manchester
was vandalized on monday but filled with
messages of support on tuesday
but less easy to erase is the criticism
of tory leaders
since the eruption of the black lives
matter movement following the murder of
george floyd in america
many conservatives have struggled with
it because of some of the movement's
messages such as defunding the police
or tearing down of statues such as this
one behind me
of cecil rhodes on oriole college in
oxford
there's an argument that conservatives
were sending popular messages that
they're fighting the war against
woke but a firm stance against racism is
also popular more than a million people
signed this oxford woman's petition
calling for racists to be banned from
football matches
when we see poisonous racist bigoted
discourse
in our public arena if it's coming from
politicians if it's coming from media
outlets wherever it's coming from
it has a profound impact on everyday
people and this is the connection
that we've made through this petition
and why so many people
come forward to sign the petition hate
will never win
jaden sancho told his fans on instagram
and to those who've been racially abused
he added
hold your heads up high and keep chasing
the dream
jason farrell sky news